[Music]
good evening welcome to tucker carlson
tonight guess what's still going on you
guessed it the impeachment trial it
continues this hour the president's
legal team currently speaking will dip
in life if anything newsworthy happens
think back to 2016 in the campaign then
Donald Trump used to recite a poem about
a woman who took a dying snake into her
house and nursed it back to health the
snake did become healthy and then
immediately whipped around and bit the
woman as she breathed her last breaths
the woman asked the snake why did she do
this well because I'm a snake was the
reply that's what we do all of which
somehow reminds us of disgraced former
national security adviser John Bolton
Republicans in Washington tonight seem
shocked to discover that Bolton has
turned and betrayed his former boss
Donald Trump but they shouldn't be
shocked that's what John Bolton is
that's who John Bolton has always been
that's what John Bolton does and not to
brag we called it long ago yesterday the
New York Times reported that Bolton's
new book contains sections designed to
help the Democratic case for impeachment
Bolden accuses the president of delaying
military aid to Ukraine in order to
pressure its government into
investigating hunter Biden again people
in Washington seems stunned by this or
claim to be if Bolton disliked Trump so
much they wonder why did he join the
administration well the answer is simple
Bolton wanted war with Iran he's always
wanted war with it all wrong he's
obsessed with it Daria's for example
gleefully fantasizing about regime
change there long before he became
national security adviser watch I had
said for over 10 years since coming to
these events that the declared policy of
the United States of America should be
the overthrow of the mullahs regime in
Tehran
and that's why before 2019 we here will
celebrate in Tehran thank you very much
in Tehran but Iran wasn't Bolton's only
targeted he also wanted more war in
Syria and war in Venezuela - he wanted
the war in Afghanistan to continue until
your great-grandchildren are too old to
serve and of course I call neo-cons he
wanted war with Russia lots of it
in 2016 bolt incited Russia is one of
America's greatest threats can you
imagine but not China for Boulton every
conflict was the final test of America's
resolve and a chance to use overwhelming
military force maybe because he never
served in the military himself
Boulton genuinely passionately loved war
in the end of course he didn't get it
Trump blocked him at the brink of more
than one conflict Moulton finally left
in well-deserved humiliation Boehner's
resignation was one of the highlights of
the president's first term a day of
celebration for normal people everywhere
but not in America's newsrooms the media
were sad to see john bolton go they
loved wars wars mean they get to move
tanks around on a screen and talk about
weapons systems and so suddenly for the
first time they love john bolton what a
hero he was bolton is something
different he's one of them and he's not
prone to just lying and you have to give
him the benefit of the doubt on
credibility because this president
deserves zero it did feel like we were
marking time and this was becoming a
planned acquittal right and yet we have
a Perry Mason moment who you gonna
believe Donald Trump or John Bolton you
could believe probably a dead frog more
than you could believe Trump at this
point John Voltan there's a lot of
things but able to be painted as the
deep state actor is not one of them so
good luck with that Republicans can now
exhale and acknowledge that the earth is
round that Donald Trump is indeed
corrupt they can rely on a man who is
the Republican version of Justice Scalia
in foreign policy circles a
conservatives conservative a
conservative conservative says a liberal
in fact the only thing john bolton
helped conserve over the past 20 years
is Raytheon's stock price he did a good
job there the many pointless conflicts
he's been pushing or not
serve it if they're just the opposite of
that they're a big part of the reason
our middle class is dying that seems
obvious to you it's not obvious here in
Washington counterproductive wars are a
virtue not advice just ask Mitt Romney
one of their biggest champions over the
last week in the Senate Romney has made
a ton of ambivalent noises about having
relevant witnesses testified to the
public hunter Biden Adam Schiff the
whistleblower who shall not be named hmm
I'm not sure not really necessary says
Mitt Romney but John Bolton Mitt Romney
would love to see his old friend John
Bolton testify before Congress keep in
mind that Bolton was once a quote senior
foreign policy adviser to Romney's
doomed presidential campaign and clearly
they're still friends I think with a
story that came out yesterday it's
increasingly apparently that would be
important to hear from John Bolton it is
pretty fair to say both John Bolton has
a relevant testimony to provide to those
of us who are sitting in impartial
justice
well John Bolton testify who knows
either way it won't change the outcome
Trump will be acquitted this is a
totally stupid shot inside she'll be
embarrassed about it later but it's
worth taking this moment to pause and
think about John Bolton himself for a
moment anyway how'd a guy who disagrees
so completely with everything that
Donald Trump ran on and won on how did
that guy wind up in a position of power
in the White House good question because
he's not the only one